That's what brings us to one of the great
discoveries
in the early years of this century,
the development of the cloud chamber.
Now Bryson Gore has been building this cloud
chamber here
for several months. It has taken months of
his life out.
And indeed this sort of thing here that Bryson
has built,
the word has already got around and people
are phoning up
and asking advice on how to build these things
from him.
So this in itself is an amazing piece of apparatus
that we've got here.
Down the bottom here we have some coolant,
which is keeping this whole evacuated thing
at the top here nice and cool.
And mists are forming inside it. You can see
the mists forming as we look.
This originally was invented by a man called
Charles Wilson.
He used to go hiking in the Scottish Highlands.
He really loved the mists and he tried reproduce
them in the laboratory.
He wanted to make atmosphere of his own to
study things with.
And as a result of that, stumbled on this
amazing fact.
That you will see shooting around little trails,
clouds seem to spontaneously form.
The reason here is that in the middle we have
got a source of radiation.
Alpha particle emitter, an alpha radioactivity.
The alpha particles are shooting out and as
they do so,
the mist forms on them.
You're not actually seeing the particles,
you're seeing their footprints.
You're seeing where they have been.
It's like a plane coming into land and you
see the mist forming on the wingtips.
This was such an amazing development that
Rutherford himself said:
"At least we've got a telescope that we can
look inside the atom
and see what's going on."
Here for the first time you're actually seeing
matter breaking down,
radiating away. The trails of those alpha
particles shooting out into the mist.
Now that is lovely and I think Bryson has
done a remarkable job here
producing this for us, I find amazing as I
watch it.
It's like eerie seeing these things happening
right before us.